thank you
welcome to the project governance group
meeting and a step back into the future
i'm cheering on behalf of nobby because
he's zooming there's no
intention of a takeover here
yeah there is
we've received one apology from the
mayors to tim
[Music]
are there any others
note the apology no uh one notification
for urgent general business
is it correct
health and safety nothing to report
michael
can we please turn to the minutes of the
previous meeting
i i think that um
that noise on zoom is the chickens at
nobby's place
oh you're right
it's i'm jerusalem
yeah
that was a that was a foul comment
[Laughter]
we had it at the uh merrell forum and
every time nobody put a speaker on mute
the noise went away
okay can we turn to the minutes for the
meeting held on the 3rd of march
are there any corrections
or comments
somebody like to move them as a true and
correct record
chair councillor lewis
yep
thank you leslie
uh all those in favor
can we move now to the project secretary
report
oh sorry minutes arising in actions were
there actions from the minutes
no
i think they're all covered
in one way shape or form right can we go
to project update
jane
uh look obviously the main thing on the
agenda is the legacy report
um
[Music]
excuse me can i ask
could all participants on zoom please uh
mute except for the person speaking
because we seem to be getting feedback
can't hear jane
try now james
is that peter yes thank you
okay so in item two you see four bullet
points these are the things we need to
cover um as we move through this
and the legacy report the dates to take
the report through to council
note a couple of extra project risks and
transferring the residual risks
after this group finishes and the future
outcomes to the risk insurance committee
in terms of the legacy report i will
work through these bullet points just
quickly
the the most important one's probably
the top one there is a missing piece of
the jigsaw
and that impacts the the
results or the
the final
report these things are all completed
now
however the writing up of the outcomes
from the
impact survey bruce's wrap-up review and
a couple of questions
in the resident survey still has to be
completed
and
the analysis done
if i could just say
i've had some feedback from lindsay
which i agree with
is that the
learnings in the report itself
need to probably go up closer to the
front
and the executive summary needs to cover
them in some
depth uh
we'll do that
but once we've got this extra piece of
information
second bullet point um as we've moved
through it you'll see the the shape has
changed there's been a lot of iterations
going on but hopefully it makes more
sense how it is
third point was a
something which you asked us to cover
last time and that was have we done what
we said we would do in terms of all the
resolutions
so an appendix a from the report
we've listed the resolutions that's the
original
28
um in
december 2020
and just noted actioned or otherwise
against them all there's only three that
we believe
haven't been completed
or
carried out as wish by council for
various reasons two of them
relate to the um
unsuccessful attempts to put
arrangements in place between the mayor
and the deputy mayor and the third one
was to be there was to be a workshop but
that turned into reviews
fourth bullet point um
the
mayor's support group will operate
outside of the working on working
together framework when we get to it
i've got a question on that because
you'll see an appendix f
not appendix f i think it's it's another
appendix i'll tell you what it is closer
to the when we get there um we've
reproduced the most recent framework
which you signed off in december and
that shows the the mayor's support group
in there so we need to decide whether it
comes out of the framework
um
workshops scheduled for the 26th of
april
and the final one's quite important but
for this group to realize that the
legacy report is your report it's how
you capture the last 18 months and
and deliver a report to council
it will have a staff covering report but
that'll be very short
on top of it so just as you i'd like you
to bear that in mind it actually says
that
at um
just under the
purpose i think it is in the report
so mr chair i do you wonder how do you
want to deal with this big long document
well look i think we should just go
straight into the legacy report and and
seek comments or any um
clarification in regard to the report
itself and then we'll come back to the
rest of the agenda
right
so that's on page
just getting there
page 19
page 19
and when you see the final version it
will all be numbered and um
look nice and snazzy
so there we go oh look i i think do you
want just do a page turn rather than me
yes
shuffling on
page 21.
so look i'm not going to be a wordsmith
um but i just asked the question it
reminds me of school when you say
presenting a report card
[Music]
fine
any others on 21
22
chain i was just in the first
piece before scene setting i was just
wondering whether
there was no mention of the long term
plan
right i'm not sure that it had any focus
on the
in the time of background
no
that's right
we were talking about the strategic
sorry my apologies under scene setting
yes you list a whole lot of things there
and i just thought you know if you look
back at the thompson report probably
with the biggest criticism was actually
the
long-term plan right yeah and i just i
just wondered whether that was the right
place but somewhere in the document i
just thought it should have some
emphasis about the success that it does
later on but
i think we're up front
any others on 22
23
there's a material to mention that only
one of the elt at the time was a
resident in indica
they
they weren't actually the elt in so far
as it was very much an interim
it was an acting so there was a lack of
a permanent elt
i think it is um yeah okay mr chair um
and we will call it interim that that's
better sure
i think it's important um jeff that we
we note those arrangements because it
was a it was a sort of the receiving
environment into which some of the
issues
that's right
it's hard if nobody lives there
a chair just on page five under the
earlier actions jane i provided a little
bit of feedback about
my um concern that in that
section
some earlier actions and some subsequent
actions were kind of mixed and it was
hard to work out what was going on
yeah you've rightly pointed out that
cheers group was formed at the time that
the um
committee structure was
was changed my point really was that was
the terms of reference that came late
as part of the
working together thing
program yeah i mean sorry
page 24 or six
cool
25
26
27
28
29 now this is where you got the work
working for working together phase two
updates
that's right
and that's an earlier version but we put
that in because it's um more
comprehensive than the one we've got now
yeah
and that's relevant to the time
yeah on 34 jane i don't want to be a
wordsmith either but under risk in the
second
paragraph please see the second
sentence of that second paragraph
um yes got it thank you
okay
uh
35
yep
36.
so jane i just had a note here under
learnings
i think one of the things that pr which
which created quite a bit of debate at
the start was that the establishing of
the working committees was whether they
had to be cheered by officers of
the organization or chaired by
councillors
yeah and i i still sort of think that
that was a really important decision in
terms of the process going forward and
we don't sort of mention that in terms
of the learnings i just think
somewhere there should be some mention
of saying
putting counsellors
in as chairs and being part of the
working groups was in a critical part of
getting things done
good point thank you
yeah i agree on that because it was some
it was a bit of a step change when that
decision was made
yes
37
38
39
oh sorry sorry me again yes sorry
that's all right um
so i just wonder and so 39 let me just
make sure i'm up so this is the what
what we could have done better yes yes
i wonder if that if there is an
opportunity just to reflect on the point
at which dia sent the letter down and
whether something should have been done
earlier to addre if there's a place
where we can sort of consider
and maybe it's the learnings for the
sector but how do you how do you
identify issues early before dia needs
to get involved
and
that's an interesting call richard
because there are probably many councils
that could be in that position yeah i'll
look it so it could be quite a political
statement to say what it is that
constitutes a
you know a problematic council and
that's and i think that's exactly the
challenge that we need to put out to the
sector and it's one of those areas where
invercargill could um you know
potentially provide some real leadership
to the sector on this typically you know
uh challenges are swept under the um
under the carpet of um
just free and frank political banter and
things like that and um
it's you you know when it gets to the
point where it's a real challenge it's
often too late so i'd be really
interested just to read some reflections
on
you know how how would how like we've
got we've got elections coming up for
almost every council around the country
in october
what advice can we give to mayors and
councillors as they get into those first
six months on how to identify when
things aren't going as well and what
steps they could they take
it might be a separate piece but i think
this is a valuable opportunity to
include that in here
so so richard when you say that
were you going to offer some suggestions
as to what those steps could be i mean
would it would it have been
a mayoral responsibility would it have
been
a risk
responsibility
yeah great point leslie i'm i'm happy to
to workshop some ideas around how we
approach that although this is very much
how it's not how dia views it um but how
how a council should identify it a good
example would be you know if you're in
your first couple of meetings of the new
triennium and all of a sudden code of
conduct issues are coming up
i think there needs to be the ability
for a council to actually just step back
and go hold on what's going on here now
have we have we prepared ourselves
properly to be like an elected council
uh is something genuinely
gone wrong or we are we missing the
point of the tools that we have
available yes so leslie it's good i'd be
happy to help support something in there
i'm just wondering whether that leads
into more comment about the
the worth of an induction program
and and for our learnings for the sector
being that it is extremely important
that that your council induction program
is absolutely thorough
yeah
at the beginning of the term and that
all councillors are given the chance to
identify issues and so forth just just
thinking about the if if we're saying
this is part of the learnings for the
sector
and are going to put in something like
that i just think it needs to be
some some meaty
um
some meaty reflections
and at least i just add to that one of
the things that made invercargill stand
out from other issues at the time a
couple of years ago was that once we did
put everything out on the table there
was genuine what i felt was genuine and
honest reflection from most of the
council is on
on what the situation was and what their
role was in that
and i think that's where
invercargill got on to the right
platform so yeah i think um you're uh
you're on the right track now
can i can i just add a bit in here
please um uh richard i look i um support
what you're what you're saying um jane i
i would though think this should be an
appendix
um i mean the legacy report richard is
about um and while i know there is a
there is a point we want to bring the
learnings up i think there are ones that
should be learnings around invocable
city council itself
um but having said that um uh
it certainly has given me good cause to
reflect what uh you know and you and i
have discussed richard what are the
warning signals and and so you know
richard's
number one report and indeed our own
self-reflection when i first became
involved clearly show those flags
but the question is
should we and can we would it be helpful
for the speaker to have those
generalized because i think at personal
view yes they should be
so i would like to see that i'm happy to
have that well sorry i would be
comfortable if it was included in legacy
report but i think
it's uh it's a separate piece that would
that would flow on from it rather than a
fair point that's yeah i'm happy with
that
i wonder if there's another way around
it to
bruce and richard
we could capture all of that in the
covering report and ask council to
attach it as an appendix to the legacy
report
would that be a better
process
because i can get it in some
appendix to the legacy report rather
than the covering letter
sorry
i just wondered if it's too late after
several meetings to attack it i can we
preempt it by making sure all the
councils get some sort of documentation
on their first meeting
or acceptance into the council
outlining some basic principles to try
to preempt
wayward behavior at ongoing meetings
because whatever three four meters down
the track and you've identified problems
then it starts to become an issue that
we have to deal with and
feelings can get hurt and you have
personalities coming into but if you
have a definitive documentation right at
the very start you might preempt some of
those problems
yeah look i think it does
look it does emphasize the importance of
induction
and and those first conversations at a
council level about how you're going to
conduct yourself
yeah steph i'm just
hiking back to my own experience and it
is that no matter how well you script it
um
people are people and personality issues
and challenges
will arise so my kind of sense is
uh flagging what those warning signals
or flags are like frequency of
notices of motion codes of conduct um
just you know tension in the atmosphere
some of the soft measures that we've
talked about is probably
what's worth
considering rather i mean
i think the induction stuff should be a
given but
again my experience is that no matter
how well that is done
there's a uniqueness about um
the sector that
almost ensures um
that
you know interpersonal
challenges
will will manifest themselves it's just
the nature of the game
it's how you recognize those and deal
with them when they get to the point
that they're impacting adversely on the
organization i think that we ought to
be considering as a legacy yeah but
these these aren't things that are
special they happen everywhere it can be
in a tennis club it's just very visible
but with respect mr chair the tennis
club doesn't get reports and get asked
to make a decision on them and then
actually decide not to make a decision
send it back for more information and
bring it back for another decision that
doesn't get a decision made on it which
is in essence what was happening with
the stones and the shoe
issues
my question back to richard would be
what does he see the role of the dia
because the letter that came from the
dia wasn't the first exchange
that had taken place between
invercargill and the dia
and if he's thinking that there's some
preemptive
um be
opportunities then what's the role with
the dia as well
we're going to think there's some really
good points that have been raised and
probably we don't at this meeting is not
the place to get into the realm of
solving the solving these problems but
um
clear's point point is a good one and we
had early on with um
we'd had invercargill on our radar for
for a um
for a number of months and there were a
couple of things that just for us was a
tipping point um i think most councils
don't realize that dia quietly just
monitors things in the background just
to understand we have all sorts of ways
that we gather information about
councils but at the end of the day at
some councils need to be left to address
their own issues i think the key point
in these learnings are
around how the councils you know step
back have a look at what's going on and
say actually maybe there's something we
need to address here i think um and on
reflection of this discussion i think
bruce is right this is um this is
something that should be appended to the
report rather than included in the
report and i think it needs a bit of
careful thinking around how we land this
to be really effective and something
that the sector can
can
actually take away and use i've got some
ideas and so i'd be happy i don't know
if anybody else is interested but you
know if we had a small group we might
consider how we actually set that out
and uh but i don't want it to it could
potentially become bigger than being
here and we don't want it to take over
from the focus of what this legacy
report is about but i do think this is a
great opportunity so i'd be happy to be
involved in something to help get that
along
so look we'll agree to uh
extending
in terms of a an appendix
probably call it appendix a give us some
rather an appendix f
and that
can i suggest that richard jane uh
and mr mckinsey is quite good in this
area is there anybody else interested in
just having a
briefing
i'll be to put my hand up for that okay
because um
as a person that deals with a good
number of codes of conduct um i probably
can add some insight thanks bruce
i think i think it would be good to keep
it to a small group but i also think if
it's going to be written as an appendix
that it does need to have some
clear steps
as to if this is identified
how does a council then deal with it and
whose responsibility that becomes
otherwise it's just going to be
um
it's just going to be another bit of
history i think
if we're going to put it in an appendix
as something useful for the sector in
the future
it definitely needs to have some
fairly clear reference to
once identified
there are some clear steps
and trigger points that a council can
take or that a mere can take or that the
dia can take on the request of the
council whatever
route i think it definitely needs that
to be part of it
okay great points leslie and um and it
makes me really think that you know this
needs to be
um non-council specifics are talking
without it's not referring specifically
to invercargill but using various
examples i wonder if there might be an
opportunity once we've got this sort of
starting to shape up to bring someone
from lg nz or somebody in as is part of
that with with their view around what
potential pathways are i think that's
really important
that councils realize they have a suite
of things that can actually they can
reach out to to help them address these
things as they come up
counselor clark norway
i'm not sure where we're heading with
this
um so if i use another analogy which is
what's the field i've worked in which is
child abuse
um so the issue is when you've had a
child abuse case and you have to take
some
serious action like
picking up a child and taking them into
care one of the processes that follows
from that is to backtrack and say
were there early intervention signs that
we should have responded to or did we
leave it too late and we got into a more
formal process
and i'm not sure that if i think about
the child abuse case that we go back to
the parents
in the case and say well you know what
could we have done or what should you
actually have done earlier on to avoid
getting into this formal process which
in our scenario is the dia intervention
i think it's for the people outside the
invercargill city council
area which is the chains and the bruces
and the richards and so on and maybe the
eas to do some background work to say
well okay
our legacy report comes forward from
thompson
and he comments back from where he was
sitting
but there is a bigger picture of how
would we avoid it and what framework
would we have so for argument's sake um
would dia if they were watching council
generically
have a mechanism that allows them to tap
into a safe route like a mirror in a
city to say look we're getting a few
issues on
we're uncoupled some of the rhetoric and
the media is not good you've had two or
three
uh successful codes of conduct
we've got poor attendance
or uptake by elected members on some
issues and that would allow a competent
mayor and i use that word
that tongue-in-cheek to be able to deal
with as an early intervention program
before dia would actually have to get
involved
so i think it's a very important piece
of work but i'm not sure that given
where we landed and what we've
subsequently done that we're in the best
position
to go back into that early intervention
area because it begs the question well
if you can sit here now
and give the country guidance on early
intervention why didn't you aggravate
the food space
so i think we should use the advices
we've got around us which those people
that i listed out and the elected
members should stay
clear of this and he even starts you're
so clear of it because it is a
system-wide issue i mean if you look at
dunedin recently major flare-up last
week over a double vote on where they
joined a breakaway three waters group um
ewe walking away from council some
members absent and some are some not not
voting and they got really messy so that
was
i guess a flash point that dia would
pick up on
but then the other issue about earlier
intervention is not necessary flash
points sometimes they can be overall
drifts that you can see a council's
reaction in the way they're governing
going downhill and you try and get them
before you get to the flash point where
it gets really messy so very in favor of
doing it not sure we should attach it to
this piece of work i think it should be
separated but it could be a good piece
of work to go forward on i guess
thanks norwich thoughts
yeah look i think nobody's read some
really good points why don't why don't
we get out this little group together
and do a bit of scoping and then we'll
make we can make a call or a
recommendation as to where it best sits
yeah
thanks richard so we're happy to do that
um and we're just leaving it
in terms of
where it finally fits and let's leave
that with the group to come back with a
recommendation
can i just clarify
jeff that yes we'll do that have to be
done quickly because this report needs
to be finished by the end of next week
in a shape to be
because we've got eastern anzac day and
so on and so forth would you expect that
the group gets together comes up with a
way forward and maybe circulates to the
pg g by email we'll get their sign off
yes but you may you may come back and
say look we think this is actually a bit
bigger than being her and that we should
actually do it separate from the legacy
report but but attached at a later stage
okay we'll come back to the whole team
not sure
i'm asking who are we doing before
uh because in the cable city is funding
okay let me just bring it right back to
the dollars and cents yeah but you know
sorry one of the things that is what
clara said one of the things that i
would propose if i'm part of that group
is that dia um actually do this piece of
work because it
it's somebody who's in the helicopter
looking at the overall um
process it's
catalysts and and the responses whose
best place i i feel
some dividends about
recommending its incorporation into this
but look
um
supporting claire's position really
let's see how it plays points yep
you got any money in the bucket richard
oh funny man
um so can i just confirm that we're
looking at myself bruce um jane and
lindsay was that before somebody else
comes
thanks richard um
so i'm sorry mr chair but i just
is there going to be some scope because
i
i'll put it bluntly i'm not authorizing
these people
to invoice invercargill for a piece of
work that invercargill isn't requesting
uh i'm happy to say let's give it an
hour and a half yep but beyond that this
is
in your words bigger than ben hur and i
think nobby might want to make a point
yep and just like to contribute to that
jeff
and it's not just a money issue for me
i think that dia is part of accepting
our legacy report should
scope and work going forward about
you know how to do early intervention
with things so they don't have a
tauranga or a invercargill situation so
they they should be the lead on that and
that's not to say that we just have the
number of people you you've suggested
that it may be that richard might want
to pull in
sam broughton or somebody else in a more
in a different council that might be
dealing with things in a different way
so we get some learning about how do we
avoid getting to tarong how do we avoid
getting down to code and what what are
the key things that we'd want to pick up
on
um as an organization and that could be
part of induction going forward we have
too many codes of conduct we have too
many um negative media reports um
and so on then there reflects that that
somebody who sits over above us should
do it i mean one of the key issues is
when i think back on these red flags is
often these red flags from people that
are pushing the
barrow out on
around democracy or freedom of speech
and the mayor and i have both been
caught up in that
um and so there is a very fine line
sometimes when you when you're in the
heat of debates when heated issues
sometimes
sit more strategically and see what's
going on it tends to be an issue by
issue basis so i think it shouldn't be
something that the dia leads
and has clear service funds
uh it wouldn't be a big excise for a
government department to say hey
actually
if we put some money and effort into
this in the next triangle we might avoid
having to spend the amount of money that
dia has already committed to this
project and probably to tarana and some
others as well
you're right rob uh you're right navi it
could be a cheap investment for the dia
it could be so look let's agree to and
thanks clear um on the basis that the
group get together
for an hour or so uh scope out what they
think is some value and come back with a
recommendation
and that recommendation may be that it
it goes to a wider extent in terms of
the dia
sounds richard
get a hand up no he's now got a thumbs
up all right supposed to be a thumbs up
hey look i'll set up the meeting for
i'll try for later this week or already
next week but bruce is now going hands
up bruce
yeah look i just um
i think what we have done is developed
bigger than being here from a good
suggestion which is i do i still think
that in this report
there is a chance for for a small piece
which is a valid part of it
self-reflection
um because i think that's what it is
ultimately knobby which is that we're
just reflecting where the signs there
originally and i think we can you know i
mean that's part of really i guess what
what was reflected in some of the early
analysis
and and i don't think in terms of the
learnings
that there's a problem with a paragraph
that would reflect look
we you know nobody you actually listed
them what we were what we were
experiencing
and the learnings are simply
if this is happening in your place be
worried
i think it would be the you know the
sort of the the colloquialism of how we
look bruce you're right i said look i
think
coming right back to the start of the
conversation raised by richard yes i
think there should be a paragraph that
refers to it and it might refer to
ongoing
work or that you know outside of the
legacy report there will be further work
being done mr chair it could be in the
cover report and it could refer to it
for the purposes of appointing the dia
to say you might want to think about
picking this up and doing some more work
but let the let the group get together
and and scope that as well but i think
to to devoid the report of any comment
would be wrong yeah and bruce you're
right there should be at least a
paragraph about it
but we'll leave the ben her part to dia
team
thank you
right page 39
i've just got one
on
the
communications and media management
there's no reflection on the current
structure
but if you went back and looked at the
time
i think solely blaming
the
continuous focus of personalities and
commentary between individual elected
members wasn't all of the problem
i
i i sense if we had probably had a calm
strategy and had been
probably more open
about what the working groups were doing
at the time we may have
had less of a problem
so i i my personal view is that the it
wasn't wasn't the lack of comments or
anything it was just the strategy around
how to deal with this
as a program from icc
probably didn't get the start it should
have got yes it got
got some focus because of personalities
etc but i still think there was i don't
know how many conversations we had in
the working group about what is the cons
mr chair i put it slightly differently
and i'd say that one of the i'll call it
an affliction but you know one of the
negative points was that the comms was
still very much
structured in a historic way
and although we knew we wanted to change
it
there was a lack of
leadership in the space to be able to
make the changes step changes that we
wanted
but but i do think in a sense of
learnings
if i was if i was ever saying to another
council about your process going forward
make sure you got your comms right
right at the start
there's no point in trying to get it
right halfway through
and i i just don't think that quite
emphasizes it enough jane
fine i've got all these points thank you
any others on 39
i'm not i'm not intending to go through
the list of appendices other than to say
here is the list
you sure there's not a couple others we
could add chair can i continue
comprehensive and international and
scope as it is yes
lindsey yeah can i just comment on that
and it's probably for you jane and it's
a sort of a form over substance
proposition i
i'm concerned that the
readability of the legacy report is
going to be overwhelmed by the
attachments or the appendices there's
about 80 pages
we might end up with 40 pages of legacy
report if we
push
and just wondered whether or not there's
another way of presenting the appendices
so that the legacy report stands alone
as a readable and accessible document
and that the
appendices potentially a
volume two or something sit there as a
historical record of the
relevant you know supporting documents
um
just uh you know we can do that i don't
know whether it's just me
or others share the concern that the
messaging
might be lost
in the massive paper that we might end
up i could help you get rid of h for a
start
um i just i just think you really need
to think seriously about
what do you need as supporting documents
to the legacy report versus a reference
to the website where you can get it
we we did think about that and we'll
take these points on board and i'm
hoping that lisa will put a thumbs up or
whatever because it will fall to how we
present this and i'm sure there's
another way to do this
i think it's a good idea to have these
all in one place um
but they don't need to be
two documents is a good idea yeah
we'll sort that because there'll be the
impact survey i think to go on the end
of it and i'm hoping that you've changed
your mind mr chair about putting an
appendix a up front because that would
mean we're gonna have to change the way
i just mean a bit further up the order
yeah okay
we'll sort that we'll come up with
something
mr chair i think there's a difference in
the appendices
i think some of them don't actually add
to telling the story and um
no disrespect but maybe h fits into that
category
whereas i think that the governance
review by mr thompson
actually
greatly adds to it and without it
um the legacy report seems a bit well
what went before
so i wonder if we actually need to
seriously think about those that uh
well i think my father would have called
me chaff
as opposed to those that really do add
to the meatiness of
the assessment and the legacy report
well i put a note to myself and i had
the letter from dia richard thompson's
report not as bio and then a six monthly
report i thought they were the three
documents yeah
every day
and i think the others can be found yes
in a particular
it's hard to read the legacy report
without having read you have to have the
thompson report and i i think for
uh
for giving some credence to the legacy
report the six month the
second report is quite critical cool um
but i think for all the other things
like the charter working together
framework those sort of things i think
should be just a reference point to the
icc website
um one question what about
the one we've got is d the
self-assessment report
no
no okay
i think you lose yeah i just look the
reason i would argue john quite strongly
on this is
i think the legacy report needs to stand
on its own and the more you have an
appendices the more it disappears
you can we can get around that jane i
mean in terms of the self-assessment
there were four key points and we've got
them
there and the extent the extent of the
wrap-up will will reference those as
they must
um
it's the four paragraphs which don't
need which can be included in the text
rather than as an opinion yes good point
that's good
any other thoughts nobody's got his hand
up oh sorry nami
was like playing a game of cheer so i
have to tell you having so many people
i'm saying nobby you've got a hand up
yeah thank you um just going back to
pace 39
which is the comms area um yeah but just
giving some thought while you're going
through the rest of the stuff there
about the comms area um so i just want
to reflect a few things there um
i think our com strategies uh was
identified very early and it seems to be
the last thing that we're resolving
well segment laughs behind induction
um and i think that's that's a learning
that we need to learn that when you're
going into something like what we've
gone through we needed to have comms up
front now there's no disrespect to lisa
because i know she's coming late to this
to this equation
um
and so that's one reflection i'd have um
there's a very fine balance between
the rights of our members to have a
democratic voice and what gets into the
media
we need to get a balance between we
should have got a balance between good
news
as opposed to always being reactive to
negative news um but the thing that
makes us quite unique i think in that
that should be in our legacy report is
that
um in defense of the comms regardless of
who was delivering it is that we had a
mayor that that actually shot us in the
foot two days after we got the thompson
report certain immediate presentation
and just
basically criticized it and ever since
then the group that's been there to
support him hasn't functioned
and ever since then every time we get a
subsequent piece of updated about the
progress we've got the mayor who's the
biggest profile we've got unfortunately
just continues to criticize it so one of
the things that we need to
identify i guess is if we had that
scenario again how would we take away
that
that constant undermining of the work we
were doing because it's been significant
um
uh and i'm not sure how you do that
given that you've got a amir that's got
a national or international profile
um
it's been very very hard work much
harder than it should have been i think
the reporter
sometimes sit here and think you know if
we'd face the thompson report and our
mayor had been dave culler who i knew
reasonably well before he passed um
i think we had a much different pathway
through what we've dealt with than if we
had that as a current man uh in
councillor sopher
councilman
just want to reflect that yeah thanks
snobby
councillor soper
ah thank you
i was just actually going to say that
nobby's um
got a fair point there that that point
does need to be perhaps a little bit
more drawn out um
but the other thing i was going to ask
were finished with the discussion on the
appendices and so forth is
where which where were you thinking of
moving the learnings to in the report
mr chi can i just ask councillor sopa to
identify which point she thought was a
fair point because i think nobby made a
couple of points
i'll just just just the difficulty of
the
of the mere undermining
the process is the point that i think
perhaps needs to be
undermining the communications process i
think probably is a point that needs to
be drawn out a little bit more
in that communications
area
look um
just shall we just deal with this point
that nobody's raised first um
on page 26
jane's captured i thought quite well
but you could argue not emphasized to
the extent you're both
raising
that on the 13th of november
the media were brought in for a brief
etc um and when the council was
surprised by the mayors chose to speak
out against the council resolutions
it's sort of buried in the report what
you're arguing is we probably need to
say something even if it was under the
comms part
and the learnings a bit more emphasizing
how that derailed it to a certain extent
or exactly
if we're going to make that comment at
the end and the learnings about
communications etc
my feeling is it does need to be drawn
out here again
that that was a very definite element
undermining the
communication i think and in fact the
agreement at that stage that we were all
on one part
i think you can do it well by the use of
the word leadership vacuum
as well
in the sense that it continually created
a problem
for the program going forward
you know
sorry jeff
um that's not strong enough for me
i knew as soon as i said it i mean
it's not a vacuum of leadership because
leadership can just be a quiet person or
person is not well organized i mean this
is quite a proactive program
by his worship to
at every single point
under mind look i i accept his right to
have a voice because i sometimes end up
down this track as well and it's a very
lonely place sometimes but when you're
trying to work through
an issue like we have with the dia
intervention
you can't afford to be undermining every
step all along the way it's it makes it
really really hard for other elected
members and senior staff that are trying
to be proactive and trying to get
forward
and trying to improve our image and the
community
to have it constantly undermined
okay i absolutely agree
if the situation had been where the
mayor had then said from the point of
the report being accepted by the council
and it led
by saying these are the things that we
need to do and prove would have been a
different and faster process
and so for that reason i think you're
right this is really hard for though for
i think for somebody crafting a report
to word it in a way that doesn't
re-litigate the whole damn thing again
too so i think there's a balance there
um but but i
take on you know i think we should take
on your comments as councillors are
saying
look at the end of the day this
kept derailing could have kept derailing
a problem that the solution
by the land
it doesn't matter how much lisa and
claire put out by way of positive
[Music]
news about what we're working here if
the mayor with his profile uh makes
one-off statements it just it just
derails everything yeah that's what
people focus on um
i mean look i don't mind him having a
voice opposed that's his right yeah i
could easily have said at that initial
media thing and said i felt a bit
um
gutted by some of the polarizing
comments about me but there was nothing
to be gained by grandstanding on that i
just had to work my way forward oh look
and we're forever grateful robbie
oh well we haven't finished a training
yet
i'm just trying to be positive and get
in the front once the legacy reports out
i can do what i like now
just come back you raised the point
around the appendix
document
just if we're going to move the
learnings i'm just interested in
where where the thoughts were on
where to move them to
sorry sorry yeah
so the royal we decided to accept all
the feedback
and and then take it all together and do
any reshaping
what i've what we're hearing is a whole
lot of stuff that will be very useful
right up front in the executive summary
don't don't forget we've got that to
emphasize a lot of the points that you
brought out today
so the answer is i don't know yet
but i think what i've heard is no
what i call material changes to the
layout other than that one may be moving
up so we'll give it some thought
but if when you get the next version it
will have the executive summary in it
which may well address
where things are we'll have to reflect
on
this very good discussion today
thanks mr chair
so are there any
other comments in terms of the legacy
report draft two
look i think that was worthwhile
discussion um
can we now move this one tip
i think it was either leslie or clear i
can't remember one of the two of them
did say about
about putting too many appendixes in um
one of the things is that when people
read through a report like this legacy
report it's about whatever number of
pages long it is and it doesn't pay as
long and then you get the penises run
into 50 or 100 pages
and go go away someone go way back when
you've read the report you've sort of
lost the
lost a bit of the
stuff that's at the front end
and so i'm just signaling that i think
like you said jane the
importance of that executive summary um
will be important because otherwise you
often it's the last thing you'll read in
a cluster of papers it tends to be fresh
in your mind
yeah
look i've taken taken on board we've
we're down to three appendices now and
they're going to be in a separate volume
of some in some way cool thank you i
think it's just as well as a draft
report because the chess report had been
more drawn out i think
righto uh
number four future reporting against
outcomes jane
um
look it's as it is yep
i've got nothing to add to that there's
you'll see
last time we added on a couple and
i'm looking at number eight
and lisa's put a comment in there about
what's been happening in march and
the organization will continue to
monitor that
to make sure that we are proactive in
communications
any questions around those comments
number
five draft work plan i think we all
agree to that
budget update
nothing to add to that
project risk
that's the one we're suggesting
that goes to the
risk and assurance
when we conclude
there's a couple added on at the end
there too 12 and 13.
any comments
and we will accept the recommendation
this will move to order some risk
or risk an audit post pgg
thank you
lisa communications update number eight
yes um
i think things have probably moved on a
little bit since that was written um
particularly in regards to the deputy
mayor um
but
yeah that's it happy to take questions
any questions
i might say i'm getting quite positive
feedback about invercargill about all
the activity around the town
in recent weeks which is nice
is dead street open again is it
it will be open by the end of this month
if you wish to be positive about steve
street you would note that the scope of
works has increased and we are
addressing stormwater issues there at
the same time i personally experienced
giving a cab ride to the airport and the
cabbie telling me that it was a
completely unnecessary piece of work and
by the time we finished our conversation
he was completely converted
well i'd like to hear from the cabbie
driver
okay nothing more under eight can we go
to nine next meeting so
yes we we shifted it to the ninth of may
because there were competing commitments
so
you just need to confirm you want to
continue with that date or bring it back
the key one is probably
all this work will have to be done to
get it out to council for the workshop
on the 26th of april and then
you recall last meeting with nobe in the
chair we had a bit of a conversation
about whether we needed
an extraordinary council meeting to deal
with this
i'm probably obviously
we don't but that's in the hands of the
group
is in the hands of pg or in the hands of
the council
so mr chair let me make a bid to start
with if the council workshop is on the
26th
then
jane would have the 27th 28th
uh jane and others to turn
it around it could be in a an agenda
published on friday the 29th for a
meeting on the 4th
it keeps it moving which i think was the
original concern
and wednesdays are the usual day for pgg
meetings
so are we missing two on the fourth is
that the problem no we're not we're not
now
is everybody happy with that
and you need to tell us just confirm
council on the 23rd
um i can't do that i'll have to refer to
the chief executive
sorry council on the 23rd of may
jane
yes so in other words we don't have a
special meeting to deal with this it
just goes to the normal
to the 24th 24th is it yeah yeah
if you wanted it to go to council early
you could have an extraordinary council
on the 10th
when there is a ppp meeting
so if you wanted to keep it i thought if
it was all lined up why wouldn't you do
it
on the 10th or the 24th yeah
i think you have to give
some
room in case something comes out of the
workshop which we then refer to the 9th
which
before we refer to the 4th yeah you'd
have overnight two all right yeah no
you do have time yeah yeah that sounds
good
i think there's another objective here
claire and
and uh jeff which is actually we what we
want to do with the report and relative
to the elections which is clearly send
it to richard
and get his response as well so
keeping keeping the pace on is helpful
in that
um that i think we we would appreciate a
response out of the department
earlier rather than later
cool i mean richard me rather than
richard thompson
yeah i said richard hardy sorry
[Laughter]
is your letter i want mate
so
so can we just um unpick that a little
bruce you're suggesting that somewhere
between the pgg
receiving the report on the fourth
and going to council
you would like it to go to the dia and
for the d.i.a sorry
what i was what i was saying um what i
was assuming actually so i should be
careful when you're checking my
assumptions which is good
so the fourth the pgg is saying to
council this is our legacy report please
accept it
um and i would have assumed on the 10th
there would have been a cover letter
saying
uh um
you know this is the final report our
proposal is or the resolution is that we
forward this to the department
um uh with a request that they they
comment essentially clearing us if it's
the right word
relative to the original letter um all
i'm trying to say is that will take some
time for the for for richard and the
team and wellington to process
and we would we would ideally want that
back reasonably soon
um uh dare i say
three of the elections that's really
what i'm trying to get so bruce supposed
to
continue that on i would ask richard a
direct question
if council met on the 10th
would the department be able to respond
by the 24th
yeah i see no reason why we couldn't i
couldn't arrange to get something back
to you by the 24th we would have been
able to have given you a you know
something earlier but the council
resolution would come on the 10th
and that's the value of a special of an
extraordinary meeting yeah
no and and look um i will have been able
to do some prep work before that anyway
so we should be able to turn around that
quickly excellent no that sounds good
thank you
everyone damn i'm giving myself a heap
of work today i know richard
this is one of those zoom calls you wish
you didn't go on
um
just in terms of your my self-interest
uh
there's another resolution that i'm
looking forward to seeing on a council
agenda and that's the termination of our
brief
is that something along with some
potentially other wrap up resolutions
that would go to the 24th
as opposed to the
temple what you're thinking
no i i would have thought that the
covering report on the 10th of may
um
is
this is the legacy report from the
pgg
please receive it
the
the resolution we've just talked about
we recommend this course to the dia and
we request
our response by the 24th
and that would be where the the
termination clause goes to i think yeah
yeah that's good
excellent
is there any other items that anybody
wanted to raise
okay
thank you very much i've got one jeff oh
sorry
just just a signal with you that you
might need to cheer
that cluster of media going forward yep
i've got an operation this friday um
cool and we'll be off for a couple of
weeks um and
depending the outcome of the pathology
on that operation i may need a further
one as well so i'm not quite sure about
the landscape going forward and what
urgent in a health system actually means
but
i've gotten quickly this time now but
it's not so well next time
okay best of luck nobody and uh happy to
cheer the meetings uh
through the in the legacy report
thank you everybody for your time i'll
let you go and do something more useful
cheers
cheers
thanks everyone thank you guys around
i'm just gonna better give you a call
again
she'll turn her phone off
you